how are you mike i'm all right man we're
uh
we're we're dealing with a couple feet
of snow here in the east but uh yeah
we're hanging in there where in the east
are you
we are in i'm actually in me and my
brother joe
have an office in providence rhode
island i know providence
i know providence rhode island yeah and
so that's where we are and actually we
do
uh we do virtual shows here i'll show
you the setup
is we go to camera one is right now we
just flip we flipped it into a studio
and it's like camera two is right here
whoa
where we have the new jokes and you got
camera three
right here and then here's the super
cam right here that's fantastic
that's peter my producer right there and
uh that's it wait a minute wait a minute
i don't let me get this straight
you have what looks to be is it four or
five cameras four
four four cam four four cameras check it
out
i've been on tv three decades
look at this i got this shot
i got this shot i got this shot
and i got this shot
i have one freaking camera we this is
what we call the around the horn and
you'll you'll relate to this as
being a mass hall yeah this is this is
we got uh
we got valentin to noma nomada fletcher
sledgehammer one move on loses the ball
the game is over
this is infuriating me mike barbeaglia
has
has four times as many cameras as i do
we do we do these we do these we're in
we're doing these
virtual shows for valentine's day
we're doing six of them it's like a live
stand-up comedy
show and we created this because
obviously i can't perform
uh in front of people yeah well it looks
fantastic
i have to say it's dynamic it's
inventive
my hat's off to you because we had all
the time in the world and
and this is uh what we got we're in an
abandoned theater
and uh you actually you actually know
this theater
you've performed here a lot this is the
famed largo theater
in los angeles largo is first of all
joking aside i appreciate what you're
doing at the show by supporting largo
one of america's greatest theaters
great theater hands down and and
actually
when when uh when i was writing the book
that you just held up the new one
um my wife and i started merging poetry
with comedy together the book has poetry
and comedy essays
and part of the the process of doing
that was at largo
we were we were i was doing the show in
los angeles and
uh and flanny who who runs the joint
over there at largo he's an irishman
yes he is uh he is a native of belfast
ireland
and i uh see him every day he's the guy
that looks after the theater
and uh and pretty much runs this place
uh and he's here every day to make sure
it's covid
safe and to tell us thousands and
thousands of stories
about belfast and five or six of those
are true conan
and but he but he would he
really encouraged them just lean in the
back come here
get your ass over here flanny
lean in it's your friend rabiglia hi
mike
hey mommy hi to johnny
they're great man so so flanny
encouraged me and jen
because i i remember i think the first
show we did was judd apatow show
at largo and judd said come do
comedy and poetry and then flanny was
the one
who was like oh comedy and poetry
i like it oh he said comedy and poetry
the only thing that's missing are blue
stars and green clovers
he does have that bootleg lucky charms
business out of the back of the
back of the theater flanny sells lucky
charms that are not
they are not made by general mills and
um
we just have to get the word out it's
like it's like bad meth that's out there
don't touch that stuff kids it'll kill
you